tu habites keisha qui la vivent et soul
timothy stone c'est arrivé partout même
dans les couples de stars c'est la
confiance en changer il ça peut arriver
de son côté comme du mien ya pas deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un certain temps que leur encontre et je
voulais le rencontrer depuis très
longtemps c'est patrice evra
catherine je veux dire tout à l'heure
c'est vrai qu'il avait une intelligence
sur le terrain on retrouve dans la vie
voilà c'est vrai qu'il ya plein mais
c'est vrai c'est il est sur le terrain
c'est un monstre a une intelligence
incroyable dans ce qu'ils aient et on le
retrouve la même chose dans la vie et
dans son livre à patrice evra et love is
game jetons vous commencez le livre part
évoqué pour la première fois
publiquement avoir été victime
d'agressions sexuelles et d'un
violoncelle directeur de l'école dans
laquelle vous logez qui vous agresser
sexuellement toutes les nuits vous
dormiez à l'école ça devait être un
cauchemar pour patrice ah ouais ben ça
ça paraissait parfait puisque voilà
j'avais plus besoin de prendre de train
m réveillé à 5 heures du matin donc ce
monsieur
il me faisait à manger je pouvais jouer
à la console de nintendo à l'époque mais
voilà chaque soir c'était c'était une
bagarre à une bagarre tous les soirs et
il a réussi le dernier soir à faire ce
qu'il avait à ce qu'ils avaient à faire
et voilà c'est quelque chose vraiment
comme je dis dans ce monde lettres
noires c'est déjà un désavantage grandir
dans une cité basse et pas de jouer les
les gangsters ou les caïds c'est une
question de survie c'est pour ça que
j'ai horreur de ces personnes de ces
célébrités qui disent oui j'étais jeune
un quartier non et puis abus sexuels à
l'âge de 13 ans bah c'est un traumatisme
mais je me suis voilà je suis une
victime mais j'ai horreur que les
personnes disent que tu es une victime
parce que j'ai rien lâché je me suis
servi de ça et ça m'a construit et
quelquefois voilà j'ai eu des impulsions
et agressif ou pas faire confiance à
l'autorité parce que je ne rendais pas
compte qu'en fait ce traumatisme ma
forme et qui je suis qui je suis devenu
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se passe et le
soir bah ils venaient dans ma chambre
dans le noir toujours le même rituel il
essayait de me toucher
donc voilà je mettais des coups mais
j'avais jamais 13 ans et j'attache et je
tenais mon pantalon pour me toucher
quand même et puis il faisait ce qu'il
avait fait au bord du lit et j'ai même
carrément un jour pris les lacets de mes
chaussures est attaché ça c'est ce que
vous dit autour de matin c'est ce que je
dis en détail mais voilà après attacher
les lacets deux attachées à ces à votre
pantalon pour pâques le directeur
boulbès voilà exactement et puis après
voilages explique en détail dans
l'innovation est ce qu'il est ce qu'il a
fait et je rajouter aussi à l'âge de 24
ans je me suis senti comme un lâche
parce que la police m'a contacté et m'a
dit monsieur vraie écoute et on a des
plaintes contre ce mu avec ce monsieur
et je sais on sait que vous avez dormi
chez ce monsieur et j'ai dit non et
après mon vous êtes sûrs et j'ai dit non
parce qu'en fait c'est pas une question
de 11 mais tu tu as tellement envie
d'effacer ça c'est quand j'ai raccroché
ben voila j'ai vécu toute cette vie avec
ce poids et je suis la femme margot
maintenant qu'ils me disaient mais patch
il ya un problème tu es un super gars
mais quand tu t'énerves cc profond
c'était vraiment à les yeux tu tu envie
de tuer et à une colère et puis après
voilà quand on a regardé une émission
sur les pédophiles et elle a vu mon
visage et qui a complètement changé elle
m'a dit qu'est ce qui se passe j'ai dit
rien dit si il ya quelque chose et puis
là je me suis lâché et je vais raconter
j'ai fondu en larmes et puis à l'arrivée
voilà c'est fou il y avait vraiment un
truc qui vous bloquez s'accroître
maintenant qu'on le sait parce que
mais même moi même je me moi je mettais
tout sur le compte du jeune du quartier
donc c'est comme ça dans le quartier
c'est une question de survie il faut
toujours se rebeller et cetera mais
c'était plus profond que ça et
aujourd'hui il se sent libérée et non
libérée heureux moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je suis quelqu'un je vis
dans le présent
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la réalité c'est
à dire que je m'en fous pas des anti va
accéder ils font ce qu'ils veulent ils
ont droit passe ils n'ont pas envie de
se faire vacciner qu'ils se fassent
vacciner
mais qui applaudissent et les médecins
et les infirmières à la première vague
est ce que faisait partie des gens qui
ne les applaudissait oui ou non oui
comment ça se fait qu'aujourd'hui les
gens qui les applaudissent aujourd'hui
disent nous on veut pas qu'ils aillent
désengorger un petit peu les hôpitaux
publics pour ceux qui n'ont pas les
moyens d'aller dans le privé
parce que les couloirs sont pleins au
congrès j'ai rien compris alors je tends
pas rien compris à temps
et nous on a compris que tu veux nonda
misogyne franchement ça m'embête à mieux
gérer ce domaine on sait si si
c'est intéressant je fais ce que je veux
c'est envie de prendre des fiches prend
des fiches c'était juste que ce que
j'aurai maintenant fait le problème tu
vas mouvement non mais écoutez ce que je
veux faire cette chose horrible ainsi
dire que je dois faire on n'est pas sur
la télé réalité on est chez cyril
hanouna non mais c'est super attention
ça vous êtes un bon connaît leurs noms
mais je vais te dire le vrai problème où
il crée un oui massif 800 millions
d'euros d'enlever 69 mille lits si on
n'avait pas fermé ses élites aurait pas
tant due aux urgences elle même on
aurait dit deux rameurs
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est parce que c'est pas de la
pole de mounir dans les si les pâtes
ainsi parce qu'il est en train de dire
non mais c'est de la faute en fait des
autres mais jamais les jours les gens
qui va le 11 ans harvey lupit sais pas
ce qu'il a dit blair s'est passé parce
qu'il était une guerre monnières
mondiaux en tout cas en parlant de
personnages qui ferait un excellent
candidat peut-être étais-je en semaine
et oui ça vient de tomber le footballeur
espagnol gerard piqué n'aime pas que
courir en chaussettes dans le sable mais
aussi voir d'autres nana en douce sauf
que shakira l'a bien grillées et du coup
lui a dit ciao déraper caixa qui la bbc
sur le timon 600 et j'ai coûté un peu
cher pour les enfants et ensembles raid
élite et ça peut coûter très très cher
et
immensément riches parce qu'à son
salaire de footballeur il a aussi une
société qui s'appelle causse moi qui
gère des tas d'événements sportifs donc
ça va lui coûter très cher elle est
partie à ibiza avec les deux enfants et
on dit que ça fait plusieurs mois en
feng qui sont plus vraiment ensemble et
lui il sort toutes les nuits ce qu'elle
n'a pas supporté avec les jeunes de
barcelone était peut-être boulanger
tu vois tu vois ma mère voilà ça peut
arriver partout même dans les couples de
stars c'est un couple et sa rive
confiance envolée toi tu as confiance la
confiance engrangée mais ça peut arriver
de son côté comme du mien ya pas deux
[Musique]
on pense forcément que ça arrive que
chez la personne médiatisée du coucou la
personne plus jeune où la personne a
maintenant ça peut arriver par bateau
mois la voilà
salonique et s'aimer se surprendre parce
que sinon c'est la mort ces mots que
j'ai fait surprendre sur elle comment
l'avez vous surprendre
[Musique]
les chiffres ont parlé de diam's et je
vous disais est ce que vous êtes choqués
par les critiques contre elle remettez
vos titres bancaires juste avant dans le
documentaire diam's fond en larmes
lorsqu'elle évoque l'épisode de paris
match en 2009 qui avait dévoilé des
photos d'elle la montrant à la sortie
d'une mosquée regardez ça ce qui m'a
vendu le triste parce qu'il ya la colère
contre le fait qu'on me voilà un truc
intimes de ma vie ça c'est clair mais ça
c'est gérable moi c'était vraiment par
rapport aux gens qui vais mais je savais
qu'ils allaient
comme brise et l'amour qu'ils avaient
entre moi et le public
s'est vraiment fait mieux faible je suis
très choquée parce que ce qu'on lui
reproche c'est de porter le voile d'être
musulmane est de faire du prosélytisme
or elle ne le fait jamais elle raconte
son histoire parce que comme l explique
son histoire allait lui être volées elle
parle d'une manière linéaire elle ne
s'apitoie pas sur elle même je trouve
son interview le documentaire très bien
et je ne comprends absolument pas ses
critiques si quelqu'un allait faire une
retraite dans un monastère à catholique
dans un monastère on dirait c'est
formidable parce qu'elle porte le voile
on la critique c'est absurde alors elle
parle aussi de ses souffrances
psychologiques elle a également évoqué
son internement ni en clinique
psychiatrique en 2008 et je me souviens
depuis la clinique et bungert commence à
me faire du mal en fait
et quand les infirmières et les gens
restent confiants ils ont dit non ça
stoppe et la balle amo est un
hymne au teint et mon camp je dis mon et
ans et qui m'ont donné plein de cash et
voilà si c'est pas sous le coup de la
loi on a le droit de critiquer sa prise
de parole on voit là je trouve que on a
droit est ce que je veux dire c'est que
sa religion et sa foi on a le droit de
critiquer au même titre que manon
religions et la laïcité ya passé pas
plus sacrées diam's que moi qui ne suis
pas religieux déjà donc ça c'est la
première chose et ensuite tu disais
gilles qu' il n'y a pas de prosélytisme
il ya eu quand même dans dans son
discours quelque chose comme la musique
ses péchés elle a quand même une
pratique de l'islam qui moi à titre
personnel si tu veux moi ça m'a fait ce
qui est absolument ce qu'elle veut de sa
vie qui moi me troue mais j'aimerais
peut-être pas que moi ma fille elle
entendre par exemple que la musique
c'est péché ou j'aimerais j'aimerais pas
qu'on dise aujourd'hui comme on le dit
beaucoup qu'elle est repenti et voilée
elle a été sauvée par l'islam j'ai pas
si vous vous rendez compte dans ce
qu'elle dit l'islam la sauver et
géraldine non mais je la cite l'islam
m'a sauvé à trouver la paix intérieure
grâce à l'islam accès de quoi je trouve
ça beau la manière dont elle parle de
religion et encore une fois je trouve
qu'à aucun prosélytisme quand elle je
crois musique ses péchés tu trouves ça
commente non mais elle dit
qu'aujourd'hui elle ne se reconnaît plus
dans ce monde les regarde je tiens la
31e sourates du coran qui proscrit la
musique voilà c'est pour ça qu'elle a
préféré arrêter une fois qu'elle a été
découverte voile et à son insu c'est
pour ça mais elle a pris la décision
d'arrêter mais elle avait le tour moi je
trouve qu'elle et moi je trouve qu'elle
est elle est inattaquable d'irwin ce
qu'est la wii elle a pris la décision
elle a été au bout de sa décision et moi
je trouve ça très bien moi je sais ma
génération donc ça me touche pour moi
diam's et si on veut
c'est quoi ces excès charles aznavour
alors oui donc moi ça me touche vraiment
pour moi diam's à les intouchables c'est
pas parce que on est connu on tire on
dit qu'un truc public que ça va
spécialement toucher nos enfants les
enfants ils ont une des parents pour
l'éducation silva les éduquer d'une
certaine manière bas c'est leur problème
si diam's l envie de dire que la musique
c'est interdit moi ça me dérange pas
qu'elle le dise si elle le pense
profondément chacun a le droit de penser
ce qu'il veut il peut être un modèle
pour les jeunes c'est un modèle mais les
jeux ne sont pas de baies et au caire
ils ont des parents si ça dérange les
parents la musique est proscrit bah
pourquoi pas après moi ce que j'aurais
aimé c'est que le dise plus tôt voilà
non nous on aurait aimé plus
d'explications plus tôt alors on est
hyper content qu'elle le fasse si
tardivement et c'est son choix mais moi
j'aurais même aimé aimer quelqu'un en
parle plutôt ouais bah oui mais laquelle
critiqué par les médias
ce qu'on
vit vraiment de se retirer vous parle en
tant que fan bien sûr qu'est ce qui
dérange pas se mentir c'est qu'elle ait
choisi de tourner d'un bébé relais
sainte anne marie léglise et alors il
fait l'église quand tu rentres au
couvent que tu viens curé turnhout
nature exacte du tueur renoncer à
l'argent tu regardes pas les moyens
ces malades dans la religion si elle a
permis de vivre mieux m c'est mal
mercredi c'est mal de se retourner vingt
ans les gens même si elle avait été elle
avait joué dans la gare entre religions
tu vas bien que la religion mais oui
mais je trouve dans la ligne que tu fais
un mauvais procès parce que cette on
voit bien sur les réseaux sociaux elle
et elle est attendue tout le temps après
par lieu sûr elle pourrait faire du
prosélytisme vraiment où on va suivre
est comme un guide spirituel elle ne le
fait pas quand elle répond à des
questions c'est vraiment à dose
homéopathique
elle a préféré faire ce documentaire
elle-même justement pour qu'on ne fausse
pas ses propos mais franchement on peut
pas dire qu'elle se montrer qu'elle fait
du prosélytisme c'est un faux procès là
je trouve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]